fans and musicians are remembering rock
legend Tom Petty this morning the 66
year old music icon died yesterday
[Music]
Fetty released the hit song don't do me
like that with the Heartbreakers in 1979
one of so many hits his career spanned
more than 40 years and inspired
generations Anthony Mason is in Las
Vegas for he'll be anchoring tonight's
evening news Anthony good morning Jeff
singer songwriter musician Tom Petty did
it all in music he sold more than 80
million albums worldwide most of them
with his band the Heartbreakers who
would share the stage with for decades
[Music]
tom petty and the heartbreakers released
their debut album in 1976 and together
created classic hits that generations of
fans would embrace
[Applause]
in 1999 petit sat down with Charlie Rose
on his PBS program and discussed how his
songs came to life you know inspiration
is really never very far away if you if
you look for it it's all around you so
this is your office well yeah I guess
you could call it that
I spoke with petit in 2009 for CBS
Sunday morning about the pressure of
working with your idols
something he did when he joined the
Traveling Wilburys in 88 the group
included former Beatle George Harrison
Jeff Lynne Roy Orbison and Bob Dylan
what's it like riding with Dylan sees
he's just as good as you think he would
be no I was there for a reason so I had
to get past his Bob nurse you know a
year later he released the first of his
three solo albums
but penny will most be remembered as the
frontman of the Heartbreakers
[Music]
just last week the band closed out their
40th anniversary tour at the Hollywood
Bowl in Los Angeles in the City of
Angels
the last song he ever performed on stage
was one of his biggest hits I really
really love this music I love I love all
music really but especially rock'n'roll
music
Tom Petty who was inducted into the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame in 2002 with the
Heartbreakers once said music is the
only real magic I've encountered in my
life it's pure and it's real it moves
and it heals this one really hurts
this one does hurt indeed as if October
2nd couldn't get bad enough the death of
a music legend Anthony thank you